you
[Music]
ok everyone I think we can get started
it's the official five minutes after the
10:30 starting time so I'm overwhelmed
introducing this woman she's so famous
she's the president of the APS she's a
distinguished professor at Northeastern
and she is a groundbreaking researcher
in the area of emotion and as we all
know this topic is so cutting-edge right
now and so politically divisive and just
so important for us to hear what the
great things about doing research in
this area are and effective things about
doing research in this area are versus
the ways it could be used for harm that
I thought she was in town to get an
award
so we with the AAAS right so we were
just so lucky to have her here so I am
without further ado I'm not gonna say
anything cuz she's gonna speak for
herself okay Lisa take it away so thank
you to Mary for the invitation what I
want to say is I'm going to be
presenting things at a pretty high a
sort of heuristic level I'm not going
into a lot of detail about data or
methods although I'm have very happy to
answer questions about that mainly what
I want to do is is give you an overall
taste of the state of the research as we
currently understand it from my lab and
basically more generally in the
literature so lots of companies
including yours are trying to detect how
people feel by reading their facial
expressions I think everyone can agree
it's a super exciting time the field is
the technology is advancing really
pretty rapidly and there is a growing
economy of emotion reading gadgets
absent algorithms but can and a machine
actually read emotion in your face well
there are plenty of companies who claim
to have done it already including yours
but what I'm going to tell you today is
that these claims are based on some
fundamental assumptions about emotion
which are probably wrong and the message
here is not that machine
can't perceive emotion or that we
shouldn't be doing this it's really more
that companies are going about it I
think in the wrong in the wrong way if
the news reports and press releases and
published papers are correct and the
there is a problem with misrepresenting
what you can do because there are
possibilities for harm but as a
scientist I'll also say I see another
really important thing to point out
which is that there is a game-changing
opportunity here with the technology
that you have that if you ask the wrong
questions you will miss so people have
in psychology and related fields have
been trying to understand the nature of
emotion for a hundred and fifty years
with very little resolution because the
our ability to collect data and analyze
those data in a dynamical systems way
and other sort of more complex analytic
ways have been until recently not
possible and so if we harness the
technology to be asking the right
questions which I have to say are hard
questions to ask because they are really
counterintuitive questions and that's
actually the punchline don't claim that
you can read anger and sadness and fear
in someone's face because you can't but
you do have technology that actually
might make that possible
well not in the face but in a person and
so let's just really dive into the
details so most in fact all emotion
reading technology that I am familiar
with usually starts with the assumption
that people are supposed to smile when
they're happy frown when they're sad and
scowl when they're angry and so on and
everyone else around the world is
supposed to recognize these frowns and
scowl and smiles as emotions as are as
is technology and this assumption is
what leads companies to claim that they
when they detect a smile on someone's
face they're actually detecting
happiness or when they detect a frown on
someone's face they're actually
detecting sadness but I'm just going to
give you one small slice
evidence here these are from these are
meta-analytic summaries so statistical
summaries of research along the x-axis
are the facial configurations which have
been hypothesized as universal
expressions of emotion and today I'm
just going to concentrate on these six
categories because this is where most of
the research has been done but
everything I'm going to say basically
holds for every emotion category that's
ever been studied in literature so how
often do people actually make these
faces to express the emotion as
hypothesized the answer is actually not
so much so on the y-axis is the
proportion of times that by the way this
is actually just making any part of that
configuration if the whole configuration
is what I would be plotting here this
would be these numbers would actually be
considerably lower okay so these numbers
are are really low this is the number of
studies that were available for analysis
this was published in 2017 and updated
in 2018 I think you stopped mid-sentence
when you were explaining what what do
those values represent like what does
point 3/4 that's what I'm about to
explain I'm sorry that's okay so this is
the number of studies which are
available for for meta-analysis and you
can see that they're really low and
which I'll explain in a moment but these
are the number of studies where what
what what some experimenters did was
they observed movements on the face as
people were induced in a laboratory
setting or in everyday life to
experience the emotion so for example
when people are angry they on average
will scowl 32% of the time that's
significantly different from chance as
is the case for all of these these are
the standard errors so in all cases
these expressions are observed when it
when expected more than what you would
expect by chance but 32% of the time is
what a scientist would call
low reliability that means approximately
70% of the time when people are angry
they are not scowling they are doing
something else with their face yes yeah
so they have so it's true that scowling
is an expression of anger but it is not
the expression of anger and in addition
people scowl when they're not angry they
scowl when they're curious or confused
or concentrating or when they have gas
they scowl for lots of reasons which is
what we would call low specificity so
people move their faces in the expected
ways significantly more than chance that
gets you a publication even in a very
good journal but what it doesn't do is
allow you to generalize from these data
to looking at someone's face and making
a really good guess exactly how they're
feeling so nevertheless even though
that's the case there are hundreds of
hundreds of studies where test subjects
are shown these posed faces and asked to
identify the emotion being portrayed and
so unlike the studies that observe
people's facial movements studies that
ask people to judge the expression in
this face the number of studies
available for analysis this by the way
was twenty years ago
the last meta-analysis was done so since
that time there are probably several
hundred more studies that have been done
so most of the research that is being
used to as the basis for emotion AI
actually comes from perception studies
where subjects are asked to judge posed
stereotypic expressions which I'll show
you a little bit more in a minute but
the important thing to understand is
that if you look at those proportions so
on average across eighty three studies
65% of the time people choose a
this is this is anger this is fear yeah
this is anger this is no this is disgust
so I should have said 0.28 but earlier
but so unlike three studies that exist
where where people faces were actually
observed there were 83 studies where
people were asked to judge this face or
face like this and 65 percent the time
on average they they labeled it as angry
so that's quite a difference right and
companies are using not the white bars
but the blue bars to to develop their
emotion a toy so how come the blue bars
are so much higher than the white bars
well here's why because in these studies
the typical paradigm is such that you
give someone a post face and then you
give them a list of emotion words and
then they're asked to choose the word
that matches the face so what's the
correct word that matches this face and
that gives you a really high on average
across all studies the average correct
response which is called accuracy uh-huh
accuracy even though these are posed
faces is 67 percent that's that's a
that's across all the studies that were
in that meta-analysis from from 20 years
ago there are many many more studies
like this now and the results are pretty
much the same and if it feels to you
like you know reading a motion on a
person's face is like reading words on a
page that's because that's in fact what
subjects are doing because when you
remove these words and you just asked
subjects to freely label the face these
are Western subjects okay from Western
urban cultures the average accuracy
drops significantly this is still above
chance but you can see that just by just
by
ending a faith alone you've really
disrupted the the finding and actually
if you use other emotion categories like
shame or contempt or embarrassment or
compassion the accuracy rate the
agreement rate drops to chance levels
now what happens when we throw a little
cultural diversity into things well
things get a lot more interesting so in
my lab we have gone to remote
small-scale cultures these are cultures
where people have very little access to
Western cultural practices and norms
these aren't ancient cultures but they
are cultures which do where people do
live in ways that are similar to the
ways that our pleistocene ancestors
lived so for example we went to Tanzania
to test the HUD's hunter-gatherers in
who live in sub-saharan Africa they are
one of the oldest populations on the
planet they have the oldest
mitochondrial DNA on the planet they've
been hunting and gathering release and
continuously since the Pleistocene I
just want to emphasize again they're not
an ancient culture they are modern
humans okay but they do live a lifestyle
which is as close to our ancestors as
we're going to find and when we give
them these faces or faces like this and
we ask them to freely label these faces
we see agreement rates drop even more
and the only reason why this is so high
is because in these experiments
typically there's only one positive
category smiling for happiness and then
there are all the negative ones so if
you just remove that positive category
then we're pretty much almost a chance
levels so basically when you start
peeling back the pieces of the this very
standard method that that experimenters
use to show evidence of universal
expressions as you start to take away
pieces of the experimental method the
evidence for universality disappears and
just to show you the power of the method
itself okay
we did an experiment also with the HUDs
a-- where what we did was we found six
emotion categories from different
cultures that have never been claimed to
be universal that don't exist in english
that don't exist in HUDs Aude because
these were we were going to test the
Hansa we wanted to test the hypothesis
that the experimental method that's been
used for the past 50 something years is
really what's making emotion categories
look as if the expressions are universal
even though they're not so we found
these six categories and then we
invented expressions for them we just
invented expressions we just made them
up basically the the study I'm going to
tell you about is a study where we made
up vocal we made up facial expressions
we also made up vocalizations so for
example for this category eagle which is
from the Philippines and it means an
overwhelming urge to squeeze or pinch
something that's very cute and so the
the sound that vocalization that we made
up for this is okay and so we just made
up these vocalizations flop them into
the method and and tested our subjects
and so the method which has been around
since the 1920s that was invented by a
man named John Dashiel this this is the
method that Paul Ekman used in his
original experiments and it's really the
method that everybody uses we only used
it here you know to make a point is that
you know you tell a little story about a
person who is has an overwhelming urge
to squeeze or pinch something that's
very cute so you tell you just give the
word and you
say which of these two expressions would
this person make and you play one sound
you play the other they pick and then
you do it again over and over and over
and over and guess what when you do that
six categories that have never been
claimed to be universal we can make five
of them look Universal basically when
you average it out you get 57 percent
accuracy or agreement which basically
it's not statistically different from
the accuracy rates that you see for
anger sadness fear disgust and so on
just against each other yeah so we can I
can basically take any in fact we could
make up a category right now give it a
word plop it into that method and make
it look Universal because the method the
method is teaching subjects to their
perceptual eLearning in the experiment
to pair whatever features you give it
you give the people vocal sounds faces
or whatever with words and so what I
like to say you know what I said to Paul
Ekman when I originally um talked to him
about this is you know he discovered
something really important actually it's
not what he thinks he discovered but he
discovered something really important
and that is words help people learn
emotion categories and they help people
learn the expressive patterns of other
people really quickly actually and
there's something really powerful and
important about that but we're not
talking about that today we're talking
about facial expressions more generally
and are they universal and how can they
be used in AI so if you have questions
about the point that I'm making about
words I'd be happy to talk about it
later I just want to get back to this
point here that the blue bars which are
the main evidence that scientists use to
make claims about universal emotional
expressions really are derived using a
family of methods that don't discover
evidence for universal expressions they
manufacture that evidence because of
what they are
subjects in during the experimental
procedure and this method which has been
around you know since the 20s is pretty
much responsible for the scientific
belief that a scowl is the expression of
anger and a smile is the expression of
happiness and so on and but the point
that I want to make today is that if you
are a company who wants to build AI to
perceive emotion in humans then you have
to pay attention to the white bars you
have to understand first of all that
facial these these very famous facial
configurations don't consistently
display the emotions that they are
claimed to display and that instead if
we put all the evidence together what we
understand is that variation is the norm
so let me show you what I mean if you
look at this person's face how does she
look to you what does she what emotion
does she look like she's experiencing
tired sad yeah well Mary's right
actually this is my daughter Sophia from
a couple of years ago she's on her
second chocolate drink at the chocolate
Museum in Cologne and she is
experiencing only what I can describe
really as a profoundly deep sense of
pleasure and this little sweetie
is also experiencing a profound sense of
pleasure and so the lesson here is that
people move their faces in many
different ways
during instances of the same emotion
category are these facial movements
random no they're not random they are
situated they are situated in an entire
ensemble of sensory features right and
behavioral features so when I say
variations the norm I'm not saying that
people just do random stuff with their
face I'm saying that
we look at each other's faces when we
talk and consciously our attention is on
other people's faces but our brains are
actually learning a huge ensemble of
sensory cues of huge pattern right we
have brains that are patterned matchers
and they are learning patterns and
that's how we're making sense of
people's of facial movements now if you
look at this little guy's just his
eyebrow region it's actually he's
scrunching his eyebrows in a way that is
very reminiscent of of the the proposed
expression for anger and this guy when
people look at him usually he looks
totally furious but when you pan out to
see the entire context he's actually you
can see that he's actually elated this
is actually does anyone know who this is
this is actually Jim Webb who won the
senatorial race in Virginia in 2006 and
returned the Senate to Democratic
control for his with his victory I just
like to take a moment simulate what that
might feel like I can tell you that when
I gave that joke in Iowa nobody laughed
it only works on the coasts and then and
then I made a comment about being from
Massachusetts and then they all laughed
so that was funny without context we see
his face as being angry because in fact
this is the face that symbolizes anger
in our culture and so it's not only the
case that people move their faces in
different ways when expressing the same
the instances of the same emotion
category it's also that they move their
faces in exactly the same way when
expressing instances of different
emotion categories the point is that in
real life a face does not speak for
itself
in experiments people see this face as
smugness or pride but actually it is the
proposed you know universal expression
for disgust and what's really
interesting is when you show subjects
these you know you
lock the head on a different body the
facial configuration is identical but
the way that subjects scan the face with
their eye movements is very different
based on what they believe what they're
guessing the expression to be so what
what's up with these expressions like
where did they come from well there's a
really interesting story about where
they come from which I don't have time
to tell you but if you ask me the
question answer period I'll be happy to
share it the the general point I guess
is that they were not discovered by
observing how people actually move their
faces in everyday life they were
stipulated by a handful of scientists
and then adopted his universal truth and
then scientists built a whole science
around them because almost every study
that has ever been published uses faces
like this posed expressions until very
recently with the advent of being able
to you know capture a moment-to-moment
facial movements in a much easier way
but basically these are Western
stereotypes they are Western stereotypes
of expressions so we have basically on
our hands a science of emojis and this
is the scientific basis that many
companies in fact most companies are
using to train their emotion AI with yep
in many cases and there are existing
datasets in some cases people are using
their own databases that they're
developing they have human they have
human coders code the faces using these
expressions as so they're not they're
using facts coding facial action unit
coding so they're coding the movement of
faces or the position of the muscles
movements position of the muscles but
they are not separating the
codes from the interpretation of the
codes so my point is that they'll label
things like instead of labeling this is
like this has you know facial action
unit 1 & 5 & 8 & 3 they'll say this is
this is actually I don't know I don't
have them memorized but like instead of
saying you know it's this ensemble of
units they'll say this is happiness this
is sadness this is anger so instead of
saying this is a scowl
they say this is anger that that one is
just descriptive the other one actually
embeds an interpretation data where the
person themselves who are that so you're
asking me actually a very good but
somewhat complicated question um I can't
say what every technology company does I
can say that the majority of scientific
studies don't do that sometimes they'll
do like one I think one of the best
datasets I've seen is from my colleague
Alicia Martinez they used words to mine
the internet to find images I think they
found something like 7 million images or
something like that so that's actually a
really good start but still these are
curated images and you know I would say
the words actually a were using were
translated into many languages but I
think 7 or 8 languages but there's still
American words like they weren't using
words that you know denote other emotion
categories that are not in English
that are you know very frequently used
you know so for example sometimes people
will say to me well how often do the
HUD's uh you know how often do they you
know frown in sadness that doesn't
that's not even a meaningful question
actually
they don't even even though they have
some of those words in their vocabulary
those work they were imported from
Swahili they're not heads on a you know
word so they they they know the words
but they just don't use them like
they're just not relevant to them right
so if this were a different talk I would
tell you about you know some
the research that we're doing where for
example we do something like exactly
like what you suggested so for example
not with faces the the pilot study I'll
just mention now is actually with
physiological features so we send people
out into we wire them up we send them
out into the world with do physiological
monitoring I'm going to talk about this
study actually a triple-a estimated
dress and we they wear the the equipment
for they come back to the lab I think
it's eight fourteen days eight hours a
day fourteen days okay and we take
resting baselines when they're sitting
standing lying down I mean just in all
sorts of positions whenever their heart
rate changes from baseline but they're
not but they're not moving their bodies
that's a psychological event and so in
that moment they are triggered to give
us the labels of how they feel then we
use unsupervised machine learning to
cluster the physiological features and
then we can look at whether those
patterns generalize across people do
they generalize across situations do the
labels you know correspond to any
particular sets of features that I mean
basically the question you're asking me
is in the direction of really what
people should be doing I will say though
that I don't think that people's own
word use is the gold standard here for
another reason and that is that people
differ in their understanding of those
words they differ in their understanding
of the meaning of those words so for
example in other research that I did
many many years ago there's actually my
dissertation part of my dissertation we
discovered that when some people use the
word anger angry they mean a pretty
distinct experience when other people
use the word angry they mean I feel bad
so for them anger and sad and fear like
angry sad and fear
are synonyms for I feel like
whereas for other people angry and sad
and fearful are distinct for some people
irritation frustration and anger are
completely distinct experiences as
opposed to synonyms for anger so just
giving just having people use words
isn't meaningful unless you actually
understand the conceptual their
conceptual understanding of those words
but that's okay because that's also a
solvable problem and basically what I'm
suggesting is if you wanna if you want
to develop a motion AI you need to build
it on data that is collected about
people's emotional episodes as they
occur in the real world in the real
world an emotion like anger or sadness
is not an entity it is a category of
instances which are full of variety now
this is a technology company and so for
those of you who do who know about
classification systems you know what a
category is a category is a group of
instances which are similar in some way
for example if you are building a cat
recognition system you would develop a
classifier that would learn the features
of cats what they have in common and to
use that to distinguish them from say
dogs or or fish or whatever right and so
this category does anyone get the pun
category yeah okay my daughter made me
put that in is a collection of instances
that have physical features now there
are plenty there's plenty of variation
in this category too right
some cats are large oops some cats are
small some cats have different eye
colors they have different thickness of
fur when they have fur at all and the
human brain tends to ignore this
variation in favor of what cats have in
common but here's the thing many
categories that we deal with in everyday
life are not defined by physical
features by the similarity of their
physical features
take this category for example everyone
in the room in this room knows this
category can you tell me what it is
hmm greyish that's good actually I
hadn't heard that one before that's very
good yeah you could say you could say
these are all these are all objects that
are grey ish of some sort yeah that's a
feature that's similar anything else one
person said these are all objects that
can shoot water I thought that was
pretty good yeah or these are things
that you cannot bring through airport
security Oh what is this little exercise
Telus it tells us that first of all the
human brain is able to do this really
amazing thing and that is with a
collection of instances we can
foreground some features and background
other features and we can actually
recategorize in just in the blink of an
eye just remarkably the other thing
though is that we can find similarities
between among objects or instances that
are not based on their perceptual
features but that are based on their
functional features their functional
features this requires the ability to
abstract to do abstraction which the
human brain is not the only kind of
animal brain that can abstract but we
have the ability to abstract in spades
and so excuse me this category exists in
your head it exists in your head and in
the head of every person who's ever
flown on an airplane it's the kind of
category that we call social reality
social reality categories of social
reality are categories where we impose
functions on an object or an event that
they normally wouldn't have by virtue of
their physical
features and we have collective
agreement about what those functions are
and as a consequence the thing then
really starts to have those functions
like can anyone think of an example of
social reality money is the best example
of social reality right you look across
the course of human history all the
things that have served for currency
share no physical features whatsoever
it's just that at that time people
agreed they could be traded for material
goods and so they could and when people
remove their agreement they withdraw
their agreement all of a sudden it
doesn't have those things don't have
value anymore
right that was the mortgage crisis
that's I mean we don't just have it's
not just money that's social reality
it's the future possibility of having
money right that's a right that's yeah
anybody else are you citizen of a
country
what's a country is a country countries
come and go boundaries come and go the
land is the same but the countries come
and go that's social reality the powers
of a president a president mmm that's
social reality so although no one's
actually said this right one of the what
we're watching now right now play out in
politics here and another place around
the world is a negotiation of social
reality when you when we allow certain
things to happen that's that that's a
way of giving consent of collective
agreement as much as actively doing
something so the point is that much of
the much of the world that we live in
that we take for granted we sort of see
it as out there physically in the world
is actually in our own heads and we're
coordinating with each other and and
expecting certain things to have certain
functions and and then they do and the
idea is that this is actually also what
emotion categories are so facial
movements and bodily changes
physical actions have physical functions
for your body but their meaning
emotionally their meaning is social
reality and it changes depending on
which culture you're in and who you are
so in one culture nodding your head has
one meaning and in another culture it
has a completely different meaning right
by virtue of social reality it's not
like we talk to each other and negotiate
what the meaning is we learn the meaning
and our brains use that meaning in in in
interpreting and guessing what facial
movements mean what physical movements
mean and so on and so forth so an
elephant has no inherent meaning as an
object that can't go through airport
security likewise a downturn mouth a
scowl is not an inherently an expression
of anger in this culture we've learned
to construct a category for anger in a
variety of situations that transforms
physical movements like a scowl or a cry
or a stone-faced stare or even a laugh
as something that has meaning as anger
that allows us to predict what that
person is going to do next and so the
punchline is that perceiving emotion
recognising emotion is not a clustering
problem it's actually a category
construction problem basically what the
human brain is doing is constantly
constructing categories and if you want
to be able to and those categories
actually direct the person's action and
if you want to understand what their
facial movements mean or what their
bodily movements mean and so on you have
to figure out how what which category
they're constructing and how they're
doing it so it doesn't matter whether
you're measuring fish
movements or vocal acoustics or
physiological activity in the body or
neural activity in the brain physical
changes by themselves have no inherent
emotional meaning somebody or something
has to make them meaningful by
categorizing them in a particular way
and that's how emotions are made and
recognized in other people so emotions
are not built into your brain from birth
they are built as you need them
by your brain to give you an intuition
of what I'm talking about here because
this is all happening outside of your
own awareness and very automatically let
me let me give you an example so does
anyone know what this is so right now
your brain billions of neurons in your
brain are attempting to make sense of
what this is to guess at what these
blobs refer to so that you can see some
image there other than black on my blubs
your brain is searching through a
lifetime of past experience issuing
thousands of guesses that you are
largely unaware of weighing
probabilities that you are largely
unaware of trying to find a good answer
to the question what is this most like
not what is this what is this most like
in my past experience what is this most
like now if you see blobs and your brain
is not hasn't found a really good match
then you are in a state that
philosophers call experiential blindness
that you're just seeing random basically
noise and you can't really make sense of
the brain can't really make sense of it
so I'm gonna now cure you of your
experiential blindness you ready yeah
when I'm talking to really big audiences
especially medical audiences I just I
stand up and I'm like are you ready to
be cured their blindness
hmm let me do it again okay now many of
you see a B or at least part of it B so
how many of you see a B or part of the B
yeah why because now when your brain
searches your past experiences you have
new knowledge there that you didn't have
before and this knowledge changes how
your brain is experiencing these blobs
your brain is basically categorizing
these blobs as a member of the category
B and as a result you see a B even
though there is no B actually there
right nothing on this image has changed
from when you saw it before even though
you see it differently now and if I were
to show you this image again in a year
from now or 10 years from now you would
still see a B and here's the other
really cool thing when I first showed
you this image and you didn't know what
it was right if I had been scanning your
brain or measuring your body your
amygdala would be going nuts not because
you were fearful but because your brain
couldn't figure out what this was and
the amygdala its rule really is not the
neural basis of fear it's to alert the
rest of the brain to when you need to
learn something so that you can better
predict later your brain can do better
prediction now that you know that this
is a B you can categorize it as a B if I
was measuring your body if your past
experience with B's if you're a gardener
and you have bucolic you know you're a
bucolic experiences with bees in your
garden your heart rate would be
reflecting that very calm sense of
tranquility but if you had been stung by
bees if you are afraid of bees then
you're seeing the bee now you would your
body would be we'd be measuring a
completely different reaction even
though the image is not
changed from before when you saw it but
the point is that when your brain
actually categorizes it's not just
making meaning in a symbolic way those
predictions those categorizations that
your brain makes actually direct your
body they direct the physical changes in
your body in the way that I'm going to
explain right now after I answer this
question other images that create almost
the same pattern and now you show me
some other image of something completely
different you know some sort of female
side and now there's going to be a
conflict and it's a B or it's a mountain
scene and I'm not sure now what I will
walk away with yeah well actually what's
really interesting is I have another I
have a lot of these are called Moony
images and they're just a really
interesting way of giving people an
intuition of the fact that they their
brains are you know we experience our
vision and all of our senses actually is
if things are out there in the world and
we're just detecting them but that's
actually not really what's happening at
all we're actually partly contributing
to our own experience even though we
don't we're not aware of that
so these Moony images are really useful
for that and I have one that is a snake
it's a blobby image and then you know
it's a snake and I have this woman came
up to me afterwards and she came out to
me she said you know I can you tell me
why you need to tell me what's wrong
with my brain and I'm like well no no no
I can tell you what's wrong he's very
much sure you know she's like well I saw
the snake for a minute and then poof I
was back seeing a Louisiana swamp and I
just saw Louisiana swamp and I could not
I just couldn't get the snake back and I
was like well and although I should say
she didn't have an accent
like you know so how long have you lived
in Louisiana it was like my whole life
and that was a blur I want to say really
like wow would you do it the accent
because like there's so I've said that
but you know but I said well here's
here's what's happening your whole life
you've lived in Louisiana so you see the
blobs as as a swamp and then I showed
you a photograph of a snake for under a
minute
so the
fires basically the probability right
that that this is in your brain that
this is a snake really are is much much
much you know lower than than a
Louisiana swamp and basically in size
your brain I mean if you were to take
your brains perspective for a minute I
think it's easy to understand a little
easier to understand how this works your
brain is basically entombed in a dark
silent box called your skull and it's
learning what goes on in the outside
world only indirectly by scraps of
information I'm from that come through
sensory channels of the body now these
are the causes of things in the world
I'm sorry these are the effects of
things in the world
these have been caused by something in
the world but your brain only has access
to the effects it doesn't know the cause
it has to guess at the cause that's a
lot of uncertainty right and ditto for
the body your brain receives sense data
from your body those are the effects of
some internal drama going on that your
brain doesn't know what caused them so
your brain Hat gets the effects and it
has to figure out what the causes are so
it has all this uncertainty how does it
guess how does it know well it has one
other source of information that it can
use oh sorry it has a reverse inference
problem to deal with all the time your
brain basically has this reverse
inference problem how does it solve it
well it it can conjure in its wiring
past experiences notice I didn't say
retrieve because your brain doesn't
store memory and it doesn't retrieve
memory those are really unfortunate
words it Rhian Stan shi'ites memory it
reads and
any given sensory input can have a range
of meanings but in a given context your
brain can use past experience to make a
pretty good guess about what the causes
are of these of these sensations so this
is how an ache in your stomach could be
anxiety if you're at a doctor's office
waiting for a test or it could be hunger
if it's dinnertime or it could be a gut
feeling that the defendant is guilty if
you are in a court room your brain
basically solves its inherent reverse
inference problem by asking the question
how are these sense data similar to
something that's happened in my past how
is it similar remember what I said about
categories categories are a collection
of things which are similar in some way
so basically what your brain is doing is
your brain is generating ad hoc
categories all the time to make sense of
sense data and if there were more time I
could show you that these categories
aren't just abstract things they are
action plans they are plans for
regulating the internal systems of your
body and they generate the sensations
that you experience and even the
feelings that you have so basically your
brain is constructing your experiences
and guiding your actions by using past
experience and forming ad hoc categories
I was gonna say more about that but I'm
running out of time and so I just want
to skip to the end if I can find my
cursor which I sent you there it is so
emotions are not your reactions to the
world they're your constructions of the
world or more precisely they're your
brains unders
standing its categorization of what is
going on in the body like an ache in
relation to what is happening in the
world like being in a doctor's office or
in a courtroom the emotions that you
experience are basically brain guesses
forged by billions of neurons working
together so the emotions that seem to
happen to you are actually made by you
categorization is also how you see
emotions in other people your brain
remembers your past experiences from
similar situations to make meaning of
the present so instead of making meaning
of blobs you're making meaning of the
Rays of an eyebrow or the curl of a lip
so to perceive emotion to recognize
emotion
your brain is categorizing the person's
facial movements and their bodily
movements and the acoustics of their
voice and their surrounding context
which also includes you know your own
body your body is a context you carry
around with you everywhere you go you
don't experience it that way but that's
how your brain works from your brains
perspective you have your own little
internal context which goes everywhere
with you and is influencing your
perceptions and your actions even though
you are largely unaware of it so this is
how a person's scowl in anger a scowl
can be anger or it can be indigestion or
it can be confusion or it could be
amusement so the emotions that you seem
to detect in other people come in partly
from inside your own head just like all
of your vision does and all of your
hearing does and all of your sense of
smell and every sensation that you have
partially from the world and partially
from your own head so this is how a
single physical feature can take on
multiple emotional meanings in different
contexts so the punchline really here is
if you wanna if you want to build a
machine that can perceive emotion in
another human in a human then it has to
be trained on something more than
stereotypes and it has to capture the
full context in high dimensional detail
not just a face or a face in a voice or
face in a body movement we congratulate
ourselves when we you know measure more
than one signal maybe two or three but
we really need to be aiming for very
high dimensional measurement very high
dimensional measurement including other
aspects of the context and our own
bodies and in a temporally meaningful
way
because part of the context is also
temporal here we're dealing with
dynamical systems and I want to point
out that when I'm using the word context
as I said before i'm using the word
really really liberally here okay
because context includes not just our
own bodies but also the bodies of other
people that were interacting with so one
of the fundamental things that we when
we're measuring emotion in some we want
to measure someone we want to measure
someone's facial movements or what have
you in order to to infer their emotions
they're usually not by themselves
they're usually in a social context we
are social animals that means a lot of
things but one of the things that means
is that we regulate each other's nervous
systems without even realizing it we are
actually we evolved this capacity as a
species it's one of our major adaptive
advantages of species and that means
that the other people around that person
not only their movements but actually
what's going on inside their body may
also be a relevant context for us to be
measuring so we want to measure physical
changes and actions that are not only in
the person of interest but in the
surrounding social context
because those may be relevant forces or
contributors to that person's movements
now I I was going to talk about um you
know move from talking about perceiving
emotion to experiencing emotion and
whether or not it's possible to build
machines that can experience emotion I'm
just gonna actually curtail this
discussion by making the point that if
if you were interested in having this
discussion
you'd really I know some people are
interested in building sentient agents
and or agents that humans interact with
who you know there's an interest in
endowing these agents with emotion the
the important thing to realize is there
are a number of ingredients that you'd
have to consider including giving the
agent a set of priors having the agent
be able to take in a large portion of
the context and understand really what
you know what emotions are for really
actually what all experiences of for and
I guess the punchline here I was going
to sort of walk you through this talk
about various points but the punchline
is this your brain every brain on this
planet did not evolve to think and feel
and see brains evolved to control bodies
your brain is a complex system that
controls a multitude of systems in your
body that's what your brain is for
amongst other things it's at least one
of the things your brain is for right
brain does lots of things but it sees
and it feels and it thinks in the
service of regulating the body so if you
want to build an agent that can
experience emotion
it has to have something like a body to
regulate I don't mean literally a
corporeal body I mean a bunch of systems
that have to be regulated because that's
actually what your brain is doing that
is the origin of your feelings the
origin of your feelings it come to
basically come your feelings come from
your brains relentless ongoing
predictive regulation of the body yep
has ablest assumptions in that for
example someone with disabilities that
severely impact their body are you
implying that they no longer experienced
emotion well yes we because that's what
I'm so what no what I'm saying is that
your brain that's not at all what I'm
saying and I wouldn't suggest that but
here's what I will tell you that your
brain is basically there are lots of
ways to talk about what your brain is
doing when it does category construction
you could say it's simulating you could
say it's making perceptual inferences
you can say it's remembering you can
call it lots of things you could say
your brain is running an internal model
it's running an internal model of your
body in the world it actually is
anticipating what's going to happen next
that's what those prediction that's what
those categorizations are there like
pre-emptive basically your brain is if
you were to take a if you were to hold
everything constant right now based on
the current sensory array
your brain is making a prediction about
what's going to happen next those
predictions actually are preparations to
see preparations to feel preparations to
move and all these sensory information
from the world and the body is doing is
either confirming those predictions or
changing them actually this is the part
that I skipped over because I was
running out of time so if you as long as
you have an internal
model of your body you don't actually
need a body really you have because you
have the capacity to have experiences of
the body even though you may actually
not receiving any a sending input at all
so for example if you have an accident
that leaves you partially paralyzed or
you know cuts cuts the nervous cuts the
spinal cord at a place where there's not
a lot of a sending information that can
make it to your brain you will still
experience you still your brain will
still can still make sensations it's
just making them mostly out of its own
predictions
that's what phantom limb pain is that's
what chronic pain is chronic pain people
who are in chronic pain are feeling pain
I mean you don't feel with your body you
feel with your brain you don't see with
your eyes you see with your brain if you
take your pulse you don't feel your
pulse in your finger you feel it in your
brain everything you experience is in
your brain so if you once had tissue
damage you act that you had some kind of
damage to your body and your body sent
nociceptive input to your brain and your
brain learned that that that that damage
was there and you feel pain then as the
damage heals sometimes it happens that
the brain doesn't get the message and it
continues to run an internal model as if
there is tissue damage when there is no
damage that person continues to feel
pain even though there's no tissue
damage anymore
that's chronic pain chronic pain is a
brain disease where people's people are
running an internal model of the brain
hasn't updated itself that may be what
depression certain types of depression
are as well so and I will say every mood
disorder that has ever been identified
whether it's part of a mental disorder
or a physical disorder has something to
do with a metabolic disruption in
regulating the body I'm not reducing
feeling to regulating the body I'm
saying your brain is all
regulating your body it's running kind
of a budget for your body it's not
budgeting money it's budgeting glucose
and salt and water and all the nutrients
that your body uses and it's doing this
on a regular basis and we're not talking
about one system or two systems we're
talking about hundreds and hundreds of
little systems so you can think about
your brain like being the financial
office of a very large company and while
this is happening your brain is sending
sense data back to your body but you
don't experience that back to your brain
but you don't experience that for the
most part because if you did you'd never
pay attention to anything outside your
own skin ever again
you're just we're not wired to
experience every little cent piece of
sense data so instead you know like
right now you're sitting there calmly
but you don't realize inside your own
body you have a drama going on of you
know epic proportions what evolution
gave us instead was simple feelings of
effect feeling pleasant feeling
unpleasant feeling calm feeling worked
up feeling like feeling comfortable
these are the affective feelings or mood
that are directly a consequence of your
brains managing of your body budget they
aren't emotion they're with you every
waking moment of your life
because every waking moment of your life
your brain is regulating your body and
every way we keep moment of your life
your body is sending information back to
your brain if you can no longer sense
your body you're still feeling effect
because of the way that the architecture
in your brain because of the way that it
does this automatic categorization
I can totally unpack that for you but
it'll take another hour the point is
that sometimes when so if you think
about affect is kind of a general
barometer of like how your body budget
is doing sometimes it's you know effect
is very intense
and in those moments that's when our
brain categorizes them as emotions at
other times we can ignore effect or we
can categorize it as something else like
some who you know cuts you off
on the highway the 'no siz in
that person right it's not really it's
actually your effect you're just
categorizing it as part of your
perception of that person so my point
here is not that not that
you know robots and other agents have to
have a literal corporeal body what I'm
saying is they have to have a set of
systems they need a balance keep in
balance and then they have to do it in a
meta minute in like in an energy
efficient way and the because those are
the requirements that your brain is
working under it has to regulate a bunch
of systems it has to do it in a in an
efficient way and and it the most
efficient thing is to do it predictively
which is really how your nervous system
is structured I had a lot more to say
but I started to you know anytime I I
start to just go off script it did I you
know run out of time so thank you for
your patience
[Applause]